I wasn't terribly upset at the Wilder
fury decision I wasn't terribly upset I
thought I thought you know what I think
Tyson Fury did enough to win but when I
look at it I like when I like when they
scored damaged damage means a lot to me
when I look at that fight when when
Wilder heard him he hurt him twice and
he hurt him real bad I mean I think
that's worth a lot and I think he was
always threatening so I felt like I
don't know if I would agree with a draw
I think it was a close decision win for
Tyson Fuhrer but I didn't hate it I
didn't hate it because I think I'd like
to see them fight again absolutely I
mean those one of them fights were yes
you're a hundred percent right that it
couldn't in the draw and I think
everybody would be kind of satisfied
with that yeah unfortunately with the
accountant knocked down which I was so
frustrated with the the comments and you
know how to stay away from the social
media and the boxing groups and and
things like that because that all just
you know the some of the opinions of
people that's the way to put it that was
a long count and this and that there's
been thousands of fights in the last ten
years and I've very seldom heard anybody
complain about a count you know that
that fight they don't do a 10-second
count in boxing they go by the referees
count right and for another thing we're
water kind of hurt himself
the referee tells you in the locker room
before the fight and he explains it to
you just go to your neutral corner if
you come out of your neutral corner I
will stop to count you mean you know
that so the first thing I used to do
when I drop somebody is I ran my ass to
that neutral corner you know so that
referee to start counting I didn't see
any issue with the knockdown I even
recorded it on my phone and if you did
go by the 10-second count Tyson Ferry
still beat it really yes I have it you
know I'd have to go through and find it
I thought I saw it on the Instagram or
one of them it was I think it was on
Wilders Instagram or he had it where the
count starts right when Fury drops I
counted it was his back almost right
before his back hits the ground into
where he got up and again that's only a
ten
second calc got a referee even coming
over to him you know okay but you know
as far as the the fight itself I gave I
gave Walter obviously to two knockdowns
that's automatically four rounds but I
thought and I gave him one other round
after that I thought Tyson fair he
controlled the action you know I had
control the momentum of the fight on the
flip side of it I think that Walter
actually could have made that easier
fight to you know Walter actually has a
hard time with his control he don't know
how to really work to the body I don't
want to put it on a trainer I don't know
what the issue is with that but he
neglected that body a lot throughout the
fight and I just thought that's why I
Tyson won most of those rounds you know
he just controlled the action the pace
and was kind of able to do what he
wanted to and I think that if Walter
went back with his trainer and watch the
tape what a fight they're gonna see a
lot of opportunities that were missed in
that fight well you know what's crazy
about Wilder is how little time he's
actually been boxing I mean it's really
stunning when he was on here he told us
that he made the Olympic team a year and
a half into weren't learning boxing yeah
and he won a bronze medal the
heavyweight division no you could kind
of get away with that - yeah you can you
know most sugar heavy fur ball back then
also we're big guys who came up usually
most of them were football players or
something like that and they kind of
just got into the sport and still even
to this day you're talking about maybe
three heavyweights that really could
throw down as where some of the other
guys are just big sloppy guys that come
in right you know so what do we got now
you got Luis Ortiz you got fury wilder
Joshua who else Joseph Parker yeah
Parker you know and I think right now
Parker is one of the guys that could
actually still upset anybody in
heavyweight division yeah especially
with that style des yes yeah so it's
getting interesting again oh it is it's
it's certainly well I think with Wilder
and fury that was one of the more
interesting heavyweight title fights in
a long time and and while they're so
it's so weird he's so different
he weighs 209 pounds he's skinny as a
rail he hits you it looks like you got
hit in the face with a missile I mean
it's crazy because that isn't miss
always firing [ __ ] crazy power that
kind
this is and I try explain to people on
that too you don't have to be a big guy
yeah you know it's all about the
leverage housing the torque were you
generate that power and you know he's
just one of them guys that that's one of
the things were you either have it you
know you got it in a cradle or you don't
and that's another one you try to
explain even like in baseball you either
a home run hitter or you're not you know
you could work on a little bit and maybe
knock one or two more home runs out or
knock a guy or two out more but if you
don't have you're not going to unless
you really go back over to find the time
and patience to reprogram that fighter
and change the whole style yeah it feels
like one punch knockout power you either
have or you don't
yeah and but the guys who can put it on
you and stop you like Julio Cesar Chavez
never had really that one punch knockout
power but he [ __ ] a lot of people up
and he had that body shot too he didn't
need a knockout punch to the head dude
he was so perfect when he was in his
prime the way he would fight was
constant bobbing weaving moving in and
then once he put that pace on you
it was just constant damage constant
punches the volume the volume the
accuracy and the fact that he never got
tired he would just keep that pace out
bap bap bap bap bap and you would see
guys just start to wilt just backing up
all the time just wilt under that
pressure that's the depth that body
attack that he had how he invested into
that body from the early rounds people
carried those punches
you know they carried that into the
fifth and sixth round and you know it
was brutal you know I couldn't imagine
fighting I fought some tough guys but I
was glad you know being a tall guy and
nobody ever went to the body like that
against me I would have hated that